found out you're pregnant
you made a decision not to keep the baby
Naya Rivera opens up about having an
abortion after breaking up with her
then-boyfriend Brian Dorsey do you still
think about it today absolutely
absolutely I think that that rings true
for any woman whether it be you know
making a decision or a miscarriage I
think it's it's it's always on your mind
and it's one of those like little scars
in life today Rivera and Dorsey are
married and have 11 month-old son
Josie the actress revealed in her new
book sorry not sorry
why she kept the abortion a secret until
the couple reunited years later what was
the main reason why he decided to have
the abortion was it because of your
career was it because you and Ryan were
no longer together there's a bunch of
different factors you know and I was
just so young when you had to tell Ryan
mm-hmm what was that like that was
really nerve-wracking he ended up saying
you know one of the best things that any
man in that situation could have ever
said and I think that it's just a true
testament to him and us and you know I'm
grateful for where we are now watch ET
Tuesday night for more from our candid
conversation with Naya and why she and
ex Big Sean called off their engagement